[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- It's time.
[SINGING]
- OK.
Let's do this.
Hands in.
Rock, on three.
One, two, three.
- Rock.
- On stage now.
[CROWD CHANTING]
[ROCK MUSIC]
[END PLAYBACK]
[SINGING]
SPEAKER 1: How about another
round of applause for them.
Are they amazing, or what?
Right?
Amazing.
Awesome.
So before we get into
questions-- first of all,
thank you all for being here.
You guys are amazing.
I had a chance to see
the show on Monday
and was totally blown away.
But before we get
to the questions,
I would love it if you could
all introduce yourselves.
Maybe say your name and then
what part you play in the show.
And maybe for the kids you
can say how old you are.
GABRIELLE GREENE: Hi.
My name is Gabrielle Greene.
I play Shonelle in the show
and I also understudy to Mika.
And I'm 12 years old.
RACHEL KATZKE: Hi.
I'm Rachel Katzke.
I play Katie the bassist.
And I'm also 12 years old.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: Hi.
I'm Levi Buksbazen.
I play Freddy the drummer.
And I'm 11 years old.
CONNER GILLOOLY: Hi,
I'm Conner Gillooly.
I'm the matinee Dewey.
And I'm 24.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: Hi.
I'm Zachary Zwelling.
I play Zack the guitarist.
And I am 11 years old.
OLIVIA CHUN: Hi.
I'm Olivia Chun.
I play Summer the band manager.
And I'm 10 years old.
JOHN ALLYN: Hi.
My name is John Allyn and
I play Billy the stylist.
And I'm 10 years old.
AMADI CHAPATA: Hi.
I'm Amadi Chapata.
I'm 11 years old.
And I play Tomika the singer.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
So, first question for you guys.
So this is obviously,
the show is
based upon the movie,
which came out in 2003.
It was a pretty major hit.
I actually learned that it was
the best-selling, best-selling
musical comedy until
"Pitch Perfect 2" came out,
which is pretty awesome.
So quick question for the kids.
Were any of you actually born
by the time the movie came out?
GABRIELLE GREENE: Well,
the movie came out in 2004,
so I was born a year after.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
GABRIELLE GREENE: I
was two years late.
SPEAKER 1: A few who are close.
But the serious question
is, so obviously it's
a very well known movie.
A lot of people know it.
How much did you
guys, when you were
getting ready for the show, how
much did you watch the movie?
How much did that
influence your characters?
Or did you mostly
learn the characters
through the process
of rehearsal?
ZACHARY ZWELLING:
So me, like, we
didn't really base our
characters off the movie.
Yeah, that movie was part
of our influence cause
it's the movie,
"School of Rock."
But our characters are kind of,
like, they're really different.
Like, so I didn't really look
up to the Zack in the movie.
But we, yeah, our
characters are different.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Anybody else?
OLIVIA CHUN: I
never, I don't think
I actually watched the movie.
I watched it like a little bit.
But when I auditioned, I
just, I did like an open call.
So I was auditioning
for anybody.
JOHN ALLYN: Well, I
mean, in my real life,
I'm kind of like Billy
cause I'm always very sassy.
But I kind of base Billy off
of me, not off of the movie.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
How about you, Conner?
Counter Because I know--
so particularly,
obviously, Jack Black,
he's not somebody who's
known for being unoriginal.
He's definitely a
strong character.
How much pressure did you
feel coming into the role,
that people are coming in
expecting to see Jack Black?
And how do you
navigate that line
between being original
but also staying
true to an iconic character?
CONNER GILLOOLY: Yeah.
Good question.
I, like, I grew up
watching the movie.
And I've always been
really influenced
by Jack Black and his
energy and his passion.
And I was a worshipper
of Tenacious D,
maybe when I was too young.
But I, when I went
into the audition,
I knew that nobody
does Jack Black the way
Jack Black does Jack Black.
So I wasn't going to go in
there and do an impression.
And I was just like,
I got to do it my way.
Because I figured like, I've
been watching him for so long
that, you know, the rocket sauce
would shine through on its own,
I think.
So I really-- and they
seemed to enjoy that.
So all of the
Deweys, they all were
encouraged to put their
own fingerprint on it
and really make it their own.
Because you know, you go in
and expect to see Jack Black.
But there's no substance
to it if you're
doing just an impression.
You know?
So it's got to come from
a real place of excitement
and like energy.
And they really
bring that out in me.
And it's just, yeah, there's
no use in doing an impression.
Because you just do it your way.
And I think they
seem to enjoy it.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
You bring up a really
interesting point,
that you are actually one of two
Deweys in the course of a week.
So do you feel-- and
it sounds like you
don't feel like you
need to portray it
the same way as the other Dewey.
How about for you guys?
Is it really different
working with different Deweys?
Do they do things
differently every time?
And what's that like?
RACHEL KATZKE: Oh,
she can go first.
AMADI CHAPATA:
Well, for me, I feel
like it's really fun being able
to have three Deweys and go on.
Because I feel like
doing like the same show
with like the same
Dewey is kind of boring.
So I love to see like different
like personalities go on stage.
And I love performing
with Connor and Justin
and everybody.
It's really fun.
GABRIELLE GREENE: Well, I
feel like all the Deweys,
they have different
kind of aspects
that make them their own.
For example, Connor, he's
so good at physical humor.
Like throughout the
show, he's so good at at.
And then Justin, like,
say something went wrong.
He, like, his improv is
literally like right on point.
Like, no hesitation at all.
So I really like
how Dewey brings out
these two in such a special way.
And they're both so talented.
SPEAKER 1: So you
mentioned improv.
So I guess, I would imagine the
show changes a lot, day to day.
Especially, I mean,
obviously there's
a lot of set, funny
written lines.
But have you guys ever
had things happen over
the course of the show that
are either something Dewey did
or something one of the kids
did that's just hilarious?
Maybe you, Levi.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: So I think,
Wednesday, the Miss Mullins
missed her entrance
into the classroom.
So Justin just started
making up a bunch of things.
And he just started rambling
for like four minutes.
And it was super funny.
CONNER GILLOOLY: Right.
It was like, it was
Mullins was coming in
and he had to cover
up and be like,
and lo, the wooden
toothed, salty
haired George Jefferson
Washington crossed
the Delaware.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: And
created the light bulb.
CONNER GILLOOLY: Yeah.
He did this and he did this.
And please come.
And he did this.
SPEAKER 1: And what's that
like for you guys when
you're on stage, right?
Because you are obviously
waiting for your lines
to come up or the
next thing to happen
when somebody has to vamp like
that for a couple of minutes?
John.
JOHN ALLYN: Well, I am
next to Marcy and Sophie,
one of the roadies, and
Marcy the backup singer.
And we were looking at each
other like, what's going on?
And I could hear the
two people around me,
we were like laughing with air.
It was like, the whole time.
And then when she finally
came in, all of us were like.
SPEAKER 1: Olivia?
OLIVIA CHUN: I think
it's really cool.
Because after
like-- even if this
is not good for like any
of the prop or the crew--
but like any time something
like a little different
happens on stage, after
we come off stage,
so Rachel and I share
a dressing room.
We're always talking like, oh,
that made our adrenaline go
up, and stuff like that.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Yeah, Gabby.
GABRIELLE GREENE: I think
it's like a daily reminder
that you always have to stay
in character and be on edge.
Like you can't get comfortable.
You have to stay on
edge and be in character
and be ready when
things happen like that.
SPEAKER 1: Totally.
So one of the things-- just
to pivot a little bit--
one of the things I think
everybody finds really
interesting, especially a show
with a lot of kids, right,
is what it's like for you guys
to do this, day in and day out.
And so one of the
things I was reading
is that a lot of you guys
actually aren't from New York,
or not even from
the New York area.
I think I saw West Coast.
I saw people from the South.
So a question, how on earth
did the producers discover you?
Amadi?
AMADI CHAPATA: One
word, Facebook.
SPEAKER 1: Wait a minute.
Could you tell us a little
bit more about that?
AMADI CHAPATA: So
well, basically,
my mom, one of her
friends saw it on Facebook
and she was like,
hey, well, there's
auditions for "School of Rock."
It's for Tomika.
Thank you.
And she has to be like 10 to 12,
I think that's what they said.
And I did a video audition.
And I sent it to them.
And I got a call back.
I did another song.
And then they asked me
to come to New York.
And I'm from Atlanta.
So it was just like in one week.
And they told me I got the part.
So I had to hurry up and move
like in a week and then start
rehearsals the next day.
SPEAKER 1: So did you move--
and this is I guess
for all of you,
too, might have
similar experiences--
did your whole family move up?
Did you move up by yourself?
AMADI CHAPATA: Just my mom.
But we didn't know if we were
going to stay for another year.
But I am, and now my
brother's moved with us.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Yeah, Zack?
ZACHARY ZWELLING: And then, so
I moved from Santa Monica, LA.
And we basically just sent
in a video, cause we're like,
it's worth a shot.
SPEAKER 1: Did you see
this on Facebook as well?
ZACHARY ZWELLING: No.
I went to like a music program
in LA, a School of Rock,
West LA, actually.
So it's like a School of
Rock learning program,
teach kids how to
play instruments.
And the head of School of Rock
was walking around one day
and I had a guitar lesson.
And he came to me, he's
like, oh, you're Zack.
You should audition for Zach.
So I'm just like, OK.
At first, I'm like, no.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
But then a little while
later he reminded me.
I'm like, why not?
So I sent in a video and six
months later I got a call back.
It said, come to New York.
And it all went off from there.
SPEAKER 1: And did your, did
your whole family move out
from the West Coast as well?
ZACHARY ZWELLING: Yeah.
My whole family moved out.
They're very supportive.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
That's amazing.
Yeah, Gabby.
GABRIELLE GREENE: Well,
I'm not too far from here.
I'm from Philadelphia.
But we still had to move here.
And like Amadi said, like
we got a week notice.
We had to move here and start
rehearsals the next day.
But open calls are
just life savers.
Like, you just go in there,
put your talent out there.
Even if they don't
select you for that,
then you know that they
have your talent information
and they can just
contact you for any part.
So that's kind of my thing.
I was just like, OK,
I'm just going to do it.
I might not get it.
Because my mindset
was I might not
get the first 100 auditions, but
eventually I'll get something.
Then a few months after,
I got a call back.
I was like, oh, OK.
And then I went there,
did the other callback,
and then they called
me saying that they
want me to do the part.
I was like, yay.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: So I
just sent in the video.
SPEAKER 1: And wait.
Where are you from, Levi?
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: I'm from
Charlotte, North Carolina.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: So I just
like, sent in a video.
I'm like, I'm not
going to get it.
It's like winning the
lottery, basically impossible.
And then I think a couple
weeks later I got a call back.
I'm like, wait.
You're telling me
I got a callback?
And then I just kept
getting callbacks.
And then they asked
me to go to New York.
I'm like, all right.
And then after
that, I got the job.
And they said, you have
a week to move up here
and you start the day after.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
Well, and because
obviously this is
sort of a different
audition probably
than a traditional
musical theater,
because for a lot of
you, you are playing
the instruments live on stage.
And for those of you who
haven't seen the show,
these guys are basically
professional level musicians.
It is amazing.
This is not like a kid's band.
This is like a band band.
So what was the audition
process like for those of you
who played instruments?
Yeah?
RACHEL KATZKE: So
I play the bass.
So I first sent in a
video of me playing
"Teacher's Pet," which is
one of the songs on the bass.
And then they called
me in for an audition.
And then it just
escalated from there.
And then I got the job.
SPEAKER 1: And by the way--
so again, for those of you
haven't seen the
show, you probably
have the best rock face of
anybody in the entire show.
Can you, would you mind
showing the face you
make when you play the bass?
Pretty bad ass.
So how about for the rest of
you that played instruments?
Like when you, like Levi,
because you play the drums.
You had to come in and
basically show them your stuff.
Did you have a preset routine?
Or did they something
that they wanted
you to play when you showed up?
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: Yeah.
So they wanted me to
play "Teacher's Pet."
And then after
that, they asked me
to play a song that I prepared.
But I didn't know that.
So I just basically just like,
oh, well, I can play this song.
So I'm just going to do that.
It was kind of
intimidating, though,
with all those other drummers.
I'm like, hmm.
SPEAKER 1: I'm sure.
So when you guys got here, so
this is a pretty intense show.
There's what, eight shows
a week for you guys?
How does that work
with going to school?
Do you go?
I've never seen so many people
excited to talk about school.
This is amazing.
We'll start with you, Amadi,
then we can work down.
AMADI CHAPATA: Well, I
have an online school.
And basically I get my subjects.
They send me, my teachers,
and I can call them any time.
So I always have help.
And I have five lessons.
And then I do, I have to do
like maybe five hours a day
or six hours a day, and
27, 25 hours a week.
But I get my
lessons from online.
And I do them, I submit them,
and then I'm done for the day.
Also, I get to be in my
pajamas and that's amazing.
SPEAKER 1: This is all through
Google Classroom, right?
AMADI CHAPATA: Yeah, of course.
JOHN ALLYN: So I go to a
public school every single day.
But when I first started,
when school started,
I went to this tutoring
program on Wednesdays
because we have a matinee.
But because it was easier
just to go to school
and have the teacher
explain the lessons to you,
I go to school every single day.
But it's kind of annoying
having to wake up
at 7:30 and after doing a show.
It's hard but it's fun.
SPEAKER 1: Olivia?
OLIVIA CHUN: So this is
my third year doing this.
I was in "The King
and I" before.
And so I started at
the age of eight.
And so for now I'm
doing public school.
Over the summer we tried
doing homeschooling.
It was a little more
difficult because my mom's not
an actual teacher,
and stuff like that.
But I go to public school.
And it's definitely
tiring, especially
having to wake up early in
the morning after a show.
But it's also, we're getting
something good out of it
because we're getting
to do what we love.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: Yeah.
I completely agree with Olivia.
It's totally all
worth it when you get
to do something that you love.
And I go to a public
school in Tribeca.
And waking up in the
morning, although it's hard--
and I feel bad for my mom
trying to get to wake--
have to wake me
up every morning--
after doing a show
the night before.
It's very tiring, but it's
something that I love,
so it's completely worth it.
CONNER GILLOOLY: I
don't go to school.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: So
I'm home schooled,
but I personally don't
like it since you don't
have like other kids there.
So.
RACHEL KATZKE: I get a mix of
homeschooling and tutoring.
So like a little bit of both.
It's fair.
GABRIELLE GREENE:
So my mom, well,
we when she was
back in Philadelphia
she used to be a principal.
So she's like,
you're doing school.
She's like, no excuses.
You're doing school.
So I just do online school.
But she's there to help
me whenever I need it.
My online school is not
a public school that's
like sending me homework.
It's basically just online.
So it's really
helpful that I have
online teachers that are just
there whenever I need them.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
And what do your friends
think about the fact
that-- or your classmates think
about that you're on Broadway?
Zack?
ZACHARY ZWELLING:
Well, I kind of like,
something that I
went by my whole life
is just always be humble.
So I don't really talk
about it much at school.
I go to school and then I
go to the show every day,
pretty much.
So with my classmates, like
on the first day of school,
cause I moved to New
York, so I was a new kid.
And on the first day of
school, some kids told me like,
you're a liar.
You're a liar.
I'm like, OK.
So.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, Amadi?
AMADI CHAPATA: Well, since
my friends are in Atlanta,
so like I can't see them every
day, which is really sad.
But I always talk to them.
And just like Zach
said, I'm always humble.
I don't really
talk about it a lot
because I don't
really want to make
anyone feel bad or anything.
And I miss them a lot.
But they're really supportive.
When I left I had a party
and it was really fun.
SPEAKER 1: Olivia?
OLIVIA CHUN: So because
I've been doing this three
years, as I said
before, a lot my friends
are really supportive.
And 10 of them have
come to see the show.
And they really enjoyed it.
But a lot of other kids
that are not in my class
are sometimes like, oh--
like Zack's friends--
they're like, oh, you're
not actually on Broadway.
I'm like, OK, whatever.
SPEAKER 1: And Connor, I know,
obviously, you're not a kid.
So your classmates are
probably not saying a lot.
But you were talking a
little bit earlier before,
and this is actually
your Broadway debut,
which is awesome.
Can you talk a little bit about
your journey getting here?
CONNER GILLOOLY:
It's crazy, man.
I graduated in 2016.
And I got an agent
through a showcase.
And I mostly did
film work up until--
I mean, I did musicals
and stuff like that.
But I thought I was just
going to pack all my stuff up
and moved to LA.
But then I got this agent
and so I moved to New York.
And I've been
living in a closet.
And I just got out--
that sounded weird.
So I went on auditions.
And I did some stand up.
And then I auditioned for the
tour and like did a callback
that same day.
And then I auditioned
for Andrew Lloyd Webber.
And then I got a call that
said I didn't get the tour.
I got Broadway.
So since the 5 of July,
life has been a whirlwind.
It's just, it's been madness.
I went from like
nannying to make money,
just barely making rent,
and then this happened.
And I started, like you
guys, it was the next day.
SPEAKER 1: That's amazing.
And like the kids in
the show, obviously, you
shred on the guitar.
It is not a joke what you
have to do on the guitar.
Were you already a guitar
player coming into the role?
CONNER GILLOOLY:
Oh, I'm lucky enough
to play with them on stage.
But I really, I knew,
I played like acoustic.
I played chords.
So the company was kind enough
to give me lessons and work
on my solo game, which
has been amazing.
Because it's like
learning another language.
And I'm just learning,
you know, I would
like to order the chicken.
You know?
Just like a little, I got
like a little solo in it.
So they really took time
to work on the stuff
that I'm playing live.
And we just really
honed in on that
just so it's good for the stage.
But now I'm sort of spreading
out and expanding my skill set.
But I didn't know, I really,
I thought I knew about guitar.
And then I got
this job and like,
just the musicians there, them,
and the house band, they're
incredible and so helpful.
And they've been so
great teaching me.
And like they're teaching
me more than anything.
Really.
SPEAKER 1: Well, you
would never know.
I mean, you look like a
pro up there, for sure.
CONNER GILLOOLY: Oh, thanks.
SPEAKER 1: So actually, speaking
of that, do all of you guys--
since you're all musicians--
are you active?
Do you do any form of
lessons throughout the course
of the show to like,
keep the skills up?
Or just playing every day
sort of makes it happen?
[INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL KATZKE: So
I like, I take,
we don't have time
for tons of lessons.
So like every once in a
while I'll take a bass
lesson and then like
voice and dance.
So like I don't have
that much time for it.
But we like try to fit
it in as much as we can.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Zack?
ZACHARY ZWELLING: For me, at the
very beginning when I started,
I think the company
provided three lessons
to learn the entire material.
And so I took
those three lessons
and then I went on the
stage and did this.
And then for the next month
I wasn't taking lessons.
And I'm like, and then I decided
like you can never, like you
never stop learning.
So I need to get
back in lessons.
So now I'm taking lessons
once a week with a teacher.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Amadi?
AMADI CHAPATA: Well, I don't
play an actual instrument
in the show.
Well, like, I do but I don't.
I play my voice.
SPEAKER 1: Which is absolutely
amazing, by the way.
Totally blows you away.
It's amazing.
AMADI CHAPATA: Thank you.
What was the question?
SPEAKER 1: If you do lessons
over the course of the show.
AMADI CHAPATA: I,
honestly, I'm so tired.
I feel like I need to rest.
I don't really
have like the time
or like the energy
to take lessons.
But my mom, she's an
actress and a singer.
So I practically get my
lessons from her at home.
So that's really easy.
And yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Olivia?
OLIVIA CHUN: So I don't play an
instrument in the show, also.
I could say I play the
triangle in the show,
but that's about it.
But I, on every Thursday,
which is my day off,
I take piano lessons.
And I've been doing that
since I was really little.
So I do that.
But then also like I
play like the ukulele
and like a little bit of guitar.
So I just like practice
at home, just for fun.
But it's Nothing professional
like these people.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Real quick, I just want
to say, we definitely
want to open it up for
Googlers to ask any questions,
if you have any.
So if you have any
questions, just make your way
to the mics on either side.
And then if
anybody's up there, I
will make sure that
we get to answer them.
So while we're waiting
to see if anybody
wants to ask any questions,
I definitely have more.
One is, so this is a show
all about rock, obviously.
Are you guys die hard rock fans?
OK.
Zack, your hand shot up.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: OK.
So I came into this
show, like, I'm
like now I consider myself an
actor and like and a dancer
and like all of this.
But I came to the show
like for the music.
I came into the
show, like, oh gosh,
I get to play my guitar
eight times a week in front
of 1,600 people a night.
Pretty cool.
So that was like, I love
the guitar, and I sing.
And my favorite band
is Led Zeppelin.
So I look up to Led Zeppelin.
I look up to Jimmy
Page, pretty much.
Like he's just amazing.
He's fantastic.
I can play a lot
of Zeppelin songs.
And so I, but now like, the
show has really taught me a lot.
It's taught me about dancing,
acting, and I've learned a ton.
SPEAKER 1: And what's
your favorite song
to shred on the guitar?
ZACHARY ZWELLING: Any
Led Zeppelin song.
SPEAKER 1: You've
trained them well.
Amadi?
AMADI CHAPATA: Well,
I didn't really
know any bands or
anything until like I
met these people, especially
the old cast that would
talk about it all the time.
This cast talks about
it all the time.
But right now, I
love Guns N' Roses.
That's one of my favorites.
And my favorite song
is "Paradise City."
One of my favorites.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
I'm actually going to
open it up real quick.
We had a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was curious at what age you
started playing instruments
or singing.
SPEAKER 1: Maybe we can
go quickly down the line,
because that would be
really interesting to know.
GABRIELLE GREENE: So I basically
started singing at seven.
But since then, one
personality thing about me
is that once I'm into something,
it's like I'm into it.
I'm doing this.
Like this is what I want to do.
So just over time
and over time, I just
started perfecting my voice.
And then this is, I decided
this is what I want to do.
RACHEL KATZKE: I started
professionally doing theater
when I was seven going on eight.
And then I started learning
bass like about two years ago,
and I learned it for the show.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: I
started playing drums
when I was about five.
So yeah.
CONNER GILLOOLY: I didn't
start doing anything til
like the seventh grade.
And there was like a
community theater I went to.
And then I just started
doing every single musical.
The first musical ever
did was "West Side Story,"
and I was a shark.
Yeah.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: I
started playing guitar
when I was seven.
And then, I totally
agree with Gabby,
that once you find
something that you love,
it's not even like,
it just, you gotta
keep doing it and enjoying it.
OLIVIA CHUN: I started playing
like the piano when I was I
think like five.
And but professionally singing
and acting and dancing,
I started when I was eight.
And then also singing and
dancing non-professionally,
I started when I was
like five or six.
JOHN ALLYN: I started doing this
professionally when I was seven
because I was also in another
show called "Peter Pan
Live," which was really fun, but
this was the big step for me.
"Peter Pan" was just
a small little step.
But this was the bigger step.
SPEAKER 1: In front
of millions of people.
A little thing called
"Peter Pan Live."
AMADI CHAPATA: Well,
I have been doing
what I've been doing,
literally, all my life.
Literally.
Because my mom, like I said,
she's an actress, singer.
So I followed her like a duck.
And like, so I get
everything from her,
like the acting, the singing.
And also my dad.
He's a musician.
So I play a little
bit of a ukulele
and a little bit of guitar.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Laura?
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
You are all so poised and
polishes at such young ages.
I'm so impressed.
Does anybody get stage fright?
And if so, how do
you overcome it?
SPEAKER 1: Gabby?
GABRIELLE GREENE: OK.
So you know like saying, like
picture everybody in underwear?
Well, I picture everyone like in
pajamas or Halloween costumes.
So that kind of makes
me laugh, like you know.
SPEAKER 1: Olivia?
OLIVIA CHUN: So on my
opening night for the show,
I was performing with
Rachel over there,
and we were both
like really nervous.
And we both were squeezing
each other's hands.
We did like a shake off.
It was really fun.
SPEAKER 1: Zack.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: So, I
don't get stage fright
but I do get nervous sometimes.
I get nervous more from the
small crowds than the Broadway.
Because when you do
something so much
and you don't tend
to get nervous
that much for like Broadway.
Also, on my opening night,
it's hard to be nervous
like when you have
so many amazing cast
mates just cheering you on,
telling you, you're awesome.
It's going to be great.
SPEAKER 1: John?
JOHN ALLYN: Well,
I joined the cast
with Zack, Gabby, and Levi.
And before I went on
stage, I enter with Levi.
And we were both really
nervous, like what Olivia said.
We were squeezing each other's
hands, taking deep breaths
in and out.
And then when we
opened the doors,
I was shocked that
I was actually
living my dream on Broadway.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
I'd love to get to
more of you, but we're
going to take another one
from the crowd real quick.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
So I'm just curious, between
school and performing,
do you actually have time for
extracurriculars, hanging out
with friends?
And if you do, what
do you like to do?
SPEAKER 1: Rachel?
RACHEL KATZKE: So, in
terms of hanging out
with school friends, I actually
don't have that much time.
Like actually last
night, my friend
wrote to me, like hey, can
we have a sleep over tomorrow
night, which is like today.
I'm like, no, sorry.
I can't because I
have a show tonight.
And then for like extra
curricular, I have--
since I'm home schooled
I have more time--
so yeah, I have a lesson
every week or something.
SPEAKER 1: Amadi?
AMADI CHAPATA: Well,
we do have days off.
Like on Wednesday, we have the
rest-- we have one matinee.
Then Thursday, whole day off.
Then today, we have
a show tonight.
But I love to hang out
with different friends.
Like a friend that actually
just left the cast,
sadly, her name is Ruthie
and she played Marcy.
We had like sleep overs
and had a lot of fun.
We went out to eat.
But we don't do too much
because we, of course,
have to get rest.
Because eight shows a
week is pretty intense.
SPEAKER 1: Olivia?
OLIVIA CHUN: So after school
on Mondays, I have a club.
On Tuesdays, I have a club.
And then on Fridays,
I have a club.
So this year, my
parents have tried
to get me more into like school,
like being like a normal child,
instead of just doing this
even though I love doing it.
I just get to hang out
with my friends after,
so I do different clubs.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, John.
JOHN ALLYN: So I don't
really see my best,
best friends until
Thursday or day off.
But I still get to see my
really good friends at school.
But what I do on my day off is
that I go to my country club
with all my friends and we
try to have as much time
as we can together because we
never get to see each other.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
I'm going to switch
you questions.
So for some of
you, I know we have
Olivia, at least you've been
in another show on Broadway.
I think for everybody else,
this is their first show
on Broadway.
Is that right?
ALL: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: So now
that you've done this,
is this what you
see yourself doing
for the rest of your life?
Or is this like, you're
just happy to have done this
and want to go do
something else?
Yeah.
GABRIELLE GREENE: Yeah.
I'm a total theater geek.
Like as soon as I
moved here, I'm like,
whoa, like I started
looking up some old shows,
listening to music, just kind of
getting out there just in case
like revivals and stuff,
there's like a lot of revivals
that's been happening recently.
So I just look up some
songs, like "Cabaret,"
I've been obsessed
with "Cabaret."
"Hamilton," of course.
SPEAKER 1: Lauren?
RACHEL KATZKE: Rachel.
SPEAKER 1: Rachel, sorry.
RACHEL KATZKE: As a kid, like
I definitely love doing this.
And I'm going to be keep doing
it like as much as I want to.
But when I'm an adult,
I'm a huge fan of animals,
so I want to be a veterinarian.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Levi?
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: So after
this, I kind of just
want to stick with my drumming
and get so much better at it,
like try and be Neil Peart-ish.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Let's just go down the
rest of the line then.
We'll take another question
from another Googler.
CONNER GILLOOLY: This
is just a stepping stone
to get to my real passion,
which is quilting.
This is cool.
I'll stay here.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: So
I agree with Levi.
The thing is, I never thought
I would be on Broadway.
Like it's all, the future
is just so unpredictable.
And I can't, I don't
ever, ever, ever want
to say that I'm
going to do this.
Like I want to, like because
I want to be able to,
I want to have options.
I want to do as many
things as I want.
And after this, if there's a
Broadway show that I really
want to do, try out for,
then I'll try out for it.
But I really, I aspire
to be like Jimmy Page.
So I like the guitar playing.
Yeah.
OLIVIA CHUN: For me, I
really love doing this.
But also, I want to be
a doctor when I grow up.
So I think, if I get another,
if I do something after this,
then like maybe I'll do it.
But it's going to be
harder because I'm
in middle school next year.
But I also, later on, maybe
after like middle school,
I just wanna, I want to kind of
be a normal child a little bit
and then move on.
JOHN ALLYN: I definitely
want to stay with this
for the rest of my life.
But after "Peter Pan,"
I needed a long break
to have time with my friends.
And I feel the same after this.
But if this doesn't
work out for me,
I also have another
thing I want to do,
and that would be
professional swimming.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
AMADI CHAPATA: Well, I
definitely want to do this.
Like I said, I've been
doing it all my life
and I really want
to stay up to this.
I will do anything that
the Lord takes me to,
and where the path goes--
Broadway, TV, anything.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
We have one more question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have another question.
You guys are so cool.
I imagine, being
on Broadway, you
get to meet other
really cool people.
Have you ever gotten to meet--
SPEAKER 1: All right.
We'll go down the
line, best star
sighting since you started.
We'll start here
and we'll go down.
GABRIELLE GREENE: Tyler Haynes
from "Cats" at Starbucks.
RACHEL KATZKE: Bruno
Mars and Ben Platt.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: Christian
Borle on his way
to "Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory."
CONNER GILLOOLY:
I met Reed Bernie.
He's a really nice guy.
Yeah.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: Probably
Michael Rucker that plays Yondu
in "Guardian of the Galaxy."
He came to see the show.
OLIVIA CHUN: I would
say Michelle Obama.
I was in "King and
I" and she came
for one of the King's last day.
And also Ben Platt
and Bruno Mars.
JOHN ALLYN: Christian
Borle, Kelly O'Hara,
Christopher Walken, Allison
Williams, and Ben Platt.
SPEAKER 1: Who?
JOHN ALLYN: Ben Platt.
AMADI CHAPATA: I honestly--
it was my opening
night, actually.
And I got to meet Bruno Mars.
I got to hug him.
He gave me a handshake.
And he told me
that I did awesome.
And I'm very sad that
I had to wash my hand.
But that's OK.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Well, we are coming close
to the end of the time.
We're going to have one more
performance from the cast.
But before we do, I have one
parting question for everybody.
All right.
So this is a school all
about rock, all about music.
You're on a desert island.
You can listen to one song
for the rest of your life.
What is it?
Amadi, we'll start on your side
and we'll work our way down.
You've been last every time.
Now you're first.
AMADI CHAPATA: OK.
OK.
I think I'm going to go with
Michael Jackson, I don't know.
All of his songs.
All of it.
JOHN ALLYN: Not to be a copier,
but I love Michael Jackson.
So his whole playlist.
SPEAKER 1: It's a good choice.
OLIVIA CHUN: Does this
have to be a rock song?
SPEAKER 1: No.
One song.
OLIVIA CHUN: If there's
one song I could pick,
it would be "Should Have
Been Us" by Tori Kelly.
She's my favorite artist.
ZACHARY ZWELLING: Can you
come back to me because this
is a hard question.
CONNER GILLOOLY: It's got to be
"Bohemian Rhapsody" by Queen.
ALL: Ooh.
CONNER GILLOOLY:
Did I steal yours?
SPEAKER 1: Crowd favorite.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN: That
was a nice answer.
I don't know if any
of you know this band,
but it's called Snarky Puppy.
SPEAKER 1: No, but I will
Google it afterwards.
LEVI BUKSBAZEN:
Google the song, "What
About Me" because I
absolutely love that song.
SPEAKER 1: By Snarky Puppy.
All right.
"Dreaming of the Broken Heart"
or "Gravity" by John Mayer,
or any song from John
Mayer's "Continuum" album.
SPEAKER 1: Nice choice.
GABRIELLE GREENE:
"Bohemian Rhapsody"
by Queen, or Roberta
Flack, "Killing Me Softly."
ZACHARY ZWELLING: OK.
He gave me the Queen idea.
So I'm going to do "Don't
Stop Me Now" by Queen.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Guys, this was so much
fun talking to you.
As everybody said, you are so
poised and fun and intelligent,
obviously.
Super talented musicians.
So thank you all so
much for being here.
I think we're going
to close it out
with one song from you, Connor.
And then if we can just
get a round of applause
to thank them for being here.
CONNER GILLOOLY: You thought
they were impressive,
be prepared to be
slightly disappointed.
Feast your eyes, your
ears, and your butts.
[SINGING]
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Can we get a round of
applause for them, everybody?
Thank you, guys.